what happens when a modern convenience
for one reason or another suddenly just
stops well as of this week that's no
longer a hypothetical question after
screenwriters in Hollywood went on
strike a few months ago last Friday the
Screen Actors Guild joined them on the
picket line and the combined strike
means that for all intents and purposes
the entertainment industry in the United
States has been shut down doesn't exist
right now the strike effects movies
television shows video games and more
it's the first time that this kind of
strike has happened in more than like
six decades I think and are always
online world of Netflix and Hulu and HBO
Max and Xbox Live this is unprecedented
and for some people it's quite
terrifying for journalists and corporate
media who spend more time glued to
screens than anyone on the planet what
we're seeing is something of an
extinction level event this is a
catastrophe approximately on the scale
of like a texas-sized asteroid hitting
the Earth